so network yeah so there's there's
actually there's two types of themes
there's what I call institutional themes
where you are you trying to show society
you're trying to show something that's
wrong with society or with a particular
institution the TV series the wire was
was genius at it because every season
was a specific institution that showed
the flaws of that institution and so
network was about you know the flaws of
society and and the TV TV business and
anything crazy right exactly but I don't
think it was a character there that
changed or transformed in the same way
that you have you know some like Star
Wars or Finding Nemo which are very
strong with character arcs and and you
know what the character learns at the
end is you know the epiphany of what
exactly you want to tell the audience
and so that reflects the theme well you
know King's Speech is another one I mean
there's a lot of really well received
films that if they're right on point
somatically even Star Wars is is
thematically rich but we don't think
about it because we we're thinking about
you know the space opera part of it in a
technology and the good versus evil but
there is a character arc in there and
it's an actually a thematic argument
through the story about what it's about
you know it's usually an argument
between two things and in Star Wars it's
it's technology versus the energy
divorce and if you look at the scenes
and you really pay attention to what
they're talking about
even Darth Vader makes that argument in
the scenes with with his superiors with
the D whatever whoever peter cushing
plays it's not the M but the Emperor no
it's not the Emperor but whoever his
boss and all these scenes you have where
he talks about the dark side of the
force and then the other side is talking
about the power of the the Death Star of
Technology and that's the argument and
then Luke and obi-wan have the argument
about the force and only the force and
if you look at the last moment that
moment where Luke has to decide versus
the force and technology right the
targeting system and at the last second
he makes that choice that's here
is epiphany that's the the decision you
could have kept you know could have
chosen the other thing that's just
technology with a force that would have
been a different story
right we're saying while technology is
more important than the force in this
case Lucas wanted to show that the force
is more important technology and that's
what Luke's decision that's what he
showed and that's that was what the
audience audiences walked away from you
know with yeah conflict and characters
and and and seeing that the character
changed through conflict does it always
have to be a living character can it can
it be a place and that's the character
can it be in in network you know the the
institution or a look at idea culture
that is more more about symbolism and in
you know art I mean yes there's like you
know Manhattan for example yells
Manhattan you know the city is a
character but but you know that's that's
that's more the art part of it in terms
of what audiences get they really the
only people they relate to the only
people we can actually connect with our
characters and in terms Pixar the
characters are human to us even though
it's a you know an ant or a fish or a
robot or a toy and the reason for that
is because they look like humans they
have eyes and they have human emotions
and human problems and so that's what we
relate to but when you see of a city
even though somebody could create a
great job do a great job about a
character in the city being a character
I don't think people were going they're
not gonna really get that on that on a
conscious level so I don't really I can
only speak to that
you